the quiet life in the countryside of
northeastern China a village in her Bay
province a world away from the
authoritarian politics of Beijing even
here though the voice of the Chinese
Communist Party rings out loud speakers
blasting revolutionary ideology were a
fixture in the days of Chairman Mao and
the Cultural Revolution now they're back
but as part of a very modern and very
intense propaganda drive by the current
regime three times a day the speakers
sound pop out Thani think you know is
your twenty dots turns around who
largely not down but then for you Lobby
I think the treaty so the clean up meets
here GD I should feed him harder we're
here on ho the system mainly broadcasts
information about agriculture technology
but it also details the policies of the
party the thoughts of Chinese President
Xi Jingping and local and national news
she's shocked what programs are created
at local government headquarters and
broadcast over the region right now
around 9,000 villages a part of what's
called the new village loudspeaker
project by 2020 it will cover 300,000
it's easy to scoff and find this all a
bit weird
even the term propaganda feels like a
Leninist hangover but we should take
this seriously because the party takes
it seriously communication is crucial to
its control it invests huge time and
resources in reaching its one point four
billion people wherever however it can
another tried and tested propaganda
technique is also making a comeback
posters featuring Xi Jinping who else
loom large but the party is taking a
different approach for tech-savvy city
dwellers like those here in Beijing more
than a hundred million people have
downloaded this app according to state
media its name is study she strong
country or if you like the little red
it features news about Xi Jingping party
policies quizzes and video lectures on
Marxism this is really well put together
out it's very sick right if you read the
news articles one in five minutes you
get bonus points for that also if you
watch videos you get bonus points so
there you have a scoreboard but I guess
if your members of the point becomes
part of your e you're affiliated to a
state organization you have a leader
board inside your institutions and if
people aren't on their phones they're
probably watching TV this game shows
cool socialism is a bit cool studying
sheet in the new era
it's the party's attempt to get
Millennials into Marxism or of course
isn't your cup of tea how about a
cartoon based on the life of a young
Karl Marx market day in another village
in urban won the loud speaker project
hasn't yet reached perhaps the biggest
obstacle the party faces is the digital
age itself like any other media outlet
it's competing for people's attention
with thousands of rivals the party
thinks reviving and revitalizing
ideology is crucial to maintaining its
power getting one village to pay
attention is a tall enough order they
let alone 1.4 billion people here like
everywhere they'd rather just get on
with their lives
Tom Cheshire Sky News Herve province